je pensais passer en terminal facile
ouais bon parce que je voyais que qu'à
travers la classe j'étais pas mauvais
puis bon ben on m'a dit tu redoubles
c'était un gros choc en plus quand on
arrive à l'école le premier jour de la
rentrée quand on arrive dans la classe
déjà sur les listes on a notre nombre
souligné puisqu'on est redoublant et on
a l'impression que que les autres élèves
bon ben on a une étiquette redoublant et
on a l'impression dans la classe d'être
un intru d'être d'être quelqu'un de pas
normal moi je l'ai vraiment senti comme
un comme quelque chose de très très
positif parce que j'ai pris confiance en
moi et puis et puis bon ben c'est pas le
banne de redoubler je veux dire on au
début c'était c'était triste parce qu'on
se dit mais j'ai j'ai loupé quelque
chose et en fait non on apprend plus par
rapport à soi par rapport aux autres par
rapport au boulot en décembre j'ai
demandé le redoublement je parlé avec
mes profs tout ça on s'est mis d'accord
puis j'ai redoublé et ta deuxème seconde
ça a été mieux